while Mark first of all thank you so
much for taking the time man to come to
your American Airlines Center you know
most people you think this is a bar you
talk to most people this would look like
a bar but this happens to be the coolest
office in the world this is your office
in the center right this is where I go
to get away it's my office my mancave my
bar when I need it preferably to
celebrate it rather than drown my
sorrows but yeah this is where I get
away well so far it's been a pretty good
start for you guys eight and fours yeah
you know we've got to play a lot better
but we'll see what happens I feel good
about how the players are playing out I
send you cyber dust you have they sing
about how I felt on yeah Dee will cuz a
lot of people thought he was but he's a
very well yeah and he's still not 100%
healthy so you know as he gets more
comfortable and gets a little bit
feeling a little bit better he's going
you better I feel that as well he's he
had at one point he was one Paul was two
if you remember that yep I know it's not
a regular guy so if he's got the fire
again he could do some stuff yeah I
think you know he's just feeling his way
a little bit and once he gets that
confidence up a little bit more he shows
those flashes of brilliance and I think
I feel the synergy when I see it so
there's some synergy with the team so so
let's get right into it at the time that
we have here together
mark biggest difference between being a
millionaire and a billionaire well would
you say the difference like the
difference between having a hundred
dollars and a thousand dollars worth a
dollar you know we're a penny and a
thousand dollars it's no difference no
no no it's huge difference I mean I've
been I've been blessed I mean I made a
lot of money at a relatively young age
and was a millionaire a few times over
but just in terms of what you can do and
the opportunities that buys there's no
comparison at the billionaire mom yeah
yeah this is crazy now how do you stay
so so so humble I mean you gotta be the
coolest cat in entrepreneurs everybody
people who follow you you got a lot of
opinions you just don't know it I'm sure
behind closed doors I see your
interviews sometimes you know you don't
but still the level of the one thing
that always impresses me with you is
because sometimes you know how guys get
to a higher level they have so many
people that hey Mark can you give me
money can you give me money kidding do
this you still are very accessible how
do you balance that accessibility and
still running all the businesses you run
well people you know that I'm close to I
know what's going on and so it's it's
really easy you know and if I don't know
you you know reach out to me on
cyberdust and I've got 30 seconds to
decide whether or not I want to know you
you know I don't do a lot of meetings I
don't do a lot of phone calls I don't do
a lot of sit downs I do almost
everything through cyberdust or email
and that makes me a lot more efficient
and gives me a lot more time in terms of
people wanting things you know it's the
best problem in the world to have and so
I try to be nice I try to be considerate
um but you know people people know me
know what's important to me and what's
not and either you fit in that or you
don't that's good to know
you know I finish your book and I watch
a lot of three pages of it but you know
what the one part in your book with the
edge that I think every entrepreneur
needs to real it's true literally I
think every entrepreneur even if it's
just the edge part well that's why I
made it so short and sweet right I want
people to see stories I wanted people to
see you know that if I can do what they
can do it um and I don't want to get
them all bogged down and you know this
little story or that little story and
try to you know try to sound smart or be
smart I figured you know the things that
have worked for me and the things that I
use to motivate myself if I could keep
it short and sweet people would actually
read it and you don't get comments all
the time this is the first book I've
read in years and I read it all in one
sitting and that was my goal and it gets
a lot done into one city yeah it's
something I guess a lot done in one
sitting okay for four bucks you can
afford it yeah absolutely
and so if you haven't read about if
you're watching you got to get the books
one of the action items at the end mark
so question I read the story you know
the whole $7,500 ring the eighty three
thousand a 85,000 the whole day you know
the the Motley eighteen year old and
then the sixteen year and all that stuff
that yeah but I'm curious if if you and
I were buddies in high school okay we're
14 years old 15 years old and we know
each other uh-huh would I bet on you
being who you are too
no chance really no chance tell me why I
mean I had my I had my good friends and
you know we we hung out and I was a
hustler there's there's no question I
was a hustler even in high school oh
yeah and into business in a big way um
but I don't I don't think people saw to
me it wasn't like people look to me oh
he's he's destined to succeed I'll show
you a picture of me in high school when
we leave I'm not gonna let you take a
picture of it all and you'll see why now
you got everybody curious you want you
can describe it but yeah I'll show it to
you but yeah I'm not gonna let you put
on camera no worries so in high school
you were the fungi were you were you
were you always the guy that made people
laugh when I was into sports not I
wasn't great at it I was just decent um
wasn't technology guy I mean I I was
into learning I was I was I was a
business guy I was I was the guy reading
about business all the time reading
business books all the time
you know going to Junior Achievement I
was a junior achievement geek why do why
were you reading business books because
I want that's what I knew I mean I was
wired that always you know I started my
first business when I was 12 I was
buying and selling baseball cards buying
and selling stamps anything I could do
to make money I was hustling and trying
to do so I was in the business but I not
so much were it was all my friends were
into it with me so they wouldn't know me
spell cards yeah baseball cards you name
it I mean I grew up in Pittsburgh and so
I would probably even less than 12 years
old I would excuse me go up by a bunch
of baseball cards that I collected and I
would package I would say okay you're
guaranteed to have a Pittsburgh pirate
in this package and I would charge three
times as much and I'd set up on this
park bench down in the park down it's
got Township where I grew up and I'd
have these little sails and it was great
I've made money you know I mean it was
you know and I learned as much about
business when I was nine ten and twelve
as I learned any other time I'm obsessed
with baseball cards there is it anything
no I wish I know I wish I still had on
but they're all long gone I gave it to
my brother who knows what happened
something about cards man I don't know
what it is you explain it to somebody
they think you're not so bad now you
learn yeah back then that's how you know
you had your favorite players and you
know you didn't see they weren't on TV
every day you
read about him in the newspaper there
was no internet and so baseball cards
were a way to connect you know I had my
Willie Stargell I have my Roberto
Clemente cards so you're not talking
about your tie back yeah there was no
pick it back then yeah so um Beck was
just getting started right so gonna you
know I don't look at it more I looked at
it just hey this is the home affinity it
wasn't like okay these were going to be
valuable at some point so yeah but it
was just you know it was just a means
yeah now you have the Honus Wagner card
you know I'm not like yeah that'd be a
cool card yeah but I've just I mean just
look look around you right I mean I got
stuff I'm just not into like I'm not a
big collector tech guy well I got your
gift man I'm with you now I wanted to
get you something and what can I get
this guy you may have it but I hope you
don't have my wife but I hope so so
let's get into entrepreneurship a little
but we already have but I you know going
into it now to focus on a little bit
what would you say out of all the
reasons in the world not regular but you
have the talent you know all these keys
to success etcetera what would you say
is the number one reason why people fail
not necessarily why they make you the
complete opposite right lack of brains
lack of effort lack of brains lack of
effort yeah they just they don't do the
work they don't learn you know when you
walk in the room when you start a
business and you start to talk about
somebody you're never in a vacuum with
no competition you know and unless
you're just extremely lucky and if
there's going to be competition that
means somebody else knows your business
as well as you do when you get started
and if you walk into a competitive
environment and they still know more
about the business than you do and more
about your customers you're going to
lose and but most people don't consider
that they don't do the work they don't
learn more about their industry they
don't know even about their business I
mean and so you've got to put in the
effort to know more about your industry
than anybody else and that's that's the
brains part and that's the effort part
as well because look if you're competing
with me you you better know what you're
doing otherwise I'm gonna kick your ass
you know and you're not gonna outwork me
and so you know the combination is
usually what kills businesses early on
more than anything
do you think so there's a part that
people say you know mark made it because
mark is a special again he became an
entrepreneur you know this guy made it
all these guys made it because they have
this special gene or whatever it is
do you think there's a proven formula
that if a brand rookie guy he's got a
lotta ambitious gun out of this rap but
not a lot of knowledge and how to do you
think if he follows a formula he's
guaranteed to make it as a porno okay so
you don't believe there's a guarantee to
make it no because who knows you're
gonna be competing with so if you put
two two people both following the same
formula both in the same industry right
which one wins yeah maybe they both can
win and both be successful but you know
so I don't I don't think there's a
DeVault default template for success but
I think there's things that you can do
to put yourself in the best position to
succeed you know so I talk about stuff
in the book you know I talk about the
one thing in business you can control
his effort you know um going out there
and sales curing all you know so I I
think you know and I agree with your
point that there are things that if you
do them you put yourself in the best
position to succeed but you know if you
just walk into a buzz you know a buzz
saw and somebody else is doing them a
little bit better you know what happens
now are you saying - to compete on your
level there's no we're just look we're
just any level right just as even if you
put a formula for me I followed it will
I eventually be able to make a quarter
million a year if I followed up one day
but I'm not talking about a hundred
million you guys pick where - right
right so how would this be wise right
yeah it was a business plan competition
and they were talking about making big
money reselling travel plans and making
$3 in affiliate commissions right it's
just not gonna happen you have that's
just more you have to be smart you can
pick the wrong things and you know
you're talking to you know alluded to
earlier about entrepreneurs being born
or built you know and I think they're I
knew I was wired to be excited about
business how or why I don't know but you
know and there's certain guys they have
the genetics to jump out of the gym
right certain guys you know that you
know when they golf they have the muscle
memory and and the discipline you know
dirt the Biscay may not be the most
talented guy in the NBA but his
discipline and his focus to do what's
necessary to be successful he's willing
to do and combine it with being seven
feet tall and being skilled you know it
makes him an amazing basketball player
so it's understanding what your skill
set is finding the right place to use
those skills and then going for it you
know will that make you 250 grand
as if you picked the right industry but
whatever industry you pick if you
outwork everybody if you try to be a
little smarter than everybody if you try
to be a better salesperson and everybody
if you try to be better prepared than
everybody you've got your best chance
because if you don't do it and somebody
else does yeah I have the same work like
someone's trying to take it all away
from you you know work you actually work
like someone's spending 24 hours working
24 hours to take it all away from you
and that's kind of the way I look at it
when you were younger did you have was
your father into business was your
mother was there an uncle somebody that
did well in business that you admire
with or somebody you read about they
said I like rockefeller I like Carnegie
nothing nothing so it's just purely user
I said I think you know my dad did
upholstery on cars
my mom did whatever odd jobs um but my
dad was always like if you want
something you have to earn it and to his
credit he never said no you can't do
that
so whether it was selling garbage bags
baseball cards stamps whatever it was he
never held me back and so I think that
was as important as anything and you
know sometimes being young and trying
things are so naive and you don't know
any better
all you do is learn and if you fail it
doesn't matter and so whether I was 9 10
12 1621 the failures were irrelevant and
you know whether you're you know nine
twelve sixteen twenty one twenty two
twenty four you know I'm sleeping on the
couch you know I have a car with a hole
in the floorboard
you know I'm living like a bum and like
a student and so what did I have to lose
and so I think that influenced me as
much as anything so it you know my dad
was like go for it
you know don't why not what do you got
to lose you know you have to sleep on a
different couch so I think that that was
motivation as much Steve said you had
the encouragement from others your
support go do it so do you think like
let's just if we put 10 guys here you
interview them okay
you could within a 5 10 minute minute
interview say this to is not gonna make
it as an entrepreneur could you pretty
much know that you know I'm not very
good at interviewing it the issue is my
interview skills more than free Gollum
horrible Shark Tank interview well yeah
it is but I get to do due diligence
after the fact right so I get my hunches
but I get your check yeah I mean I can I
can typically tell right I can tell
um but by um
their passion I can tell by their focus
I can tell by their preparation you know
there's a whole realm of things than any
business here you know here's here's the
business you're in and here's a thousand
things that influence whether or not
you're going to be successful and really
to me by you know through my experience
and businesses I can put myself in his
position and say okay here are nine
hundred of the thousand things he has to
be aware of and then go through and ask
and by how many of those or her issues
they've been able to address already
that kind of gives me a sense of how
hard they're willing to work you know
and I can tell by the questions they ask
me so all I have to do is say okay what
do you want to know and you know when
they start saying what should I do
they ask you yeah what you know and
that's fine right and I want them to ask
questions but you know people like to
say you know the only stupid questions
are the one you don't once you don't ask
that's not right right because the
questions you ask tell everybody
tell me tell whoever more about you than
anything else you do because in
particular tells me about your
preparation if you ask me questions
about just basic things that you should
have known and you should have down to a
science
that's gonna disqualify you almost more
than anything I've read this cyber
that's we send out by the way but now I
got to get the questions right I said
okay I'll take that as a challenge
that's another bird I stopped flying
sound like when I have a saw it was
great yeah so no it's phenomenal what
the question you asked are critical are
you reads it's complete opposite on the
way you you know the traditional way of
thinking and I always ask the question
so mark you're now you know whatever
your net worth is billions of dollars
you own a sports team you have
businesses you're in Shark Tank you're
on TV shows everybody wants your time
how hard is it for you now this is the
thing I think about because for my so I
run a business it's harder for me to
make friends now and let people in my
circle but I'm not at your level how is
it when a person like you is it still
easy to make friends now I'm not out
there you know at this world I'm not out
there looking me you know I don't need
any new writing buddies I mean my high
school buddies are still my friends my
college buddies got rugby buddies um the
guys I when I first came to Dallas that
were my friends then are my friends now
you know I've got three kids you know so
it's more you know my family just takes
up so much my time along with business
up
I'm not you know and even back in the
day when I was single I was still
successful I could tell the gold diggers
from the the real friends I mean you
know it was pretty easy got it
did association play a big role with you
or not really yeah for you yeah as you
were so determined it didn't matter
nobody could influence you influence
other PA I just I just want to do my
thing made sense make sense um couple
words I'll just put out that I want to
see what you think about it because I
watch you and I watch some of these
other guys and I see a sense of paranoia
and I don't know if you read the book
the only the paranoid survive ten twenty
great book that was written do you think
there needs to be a healthy level of
peril absolutely they're nice too oh
yeah I mean I I always say you know for
every one of my businesses I said what
would I do to kick my own ass you're
right so whatever business you have
there's somebody's trying to put you out
of business there's somebody trying to
to take a bite out of your business and
it's better for you to figure out how
they're going to do it rather than they
do it and so yeah that's being paranoid
and so you have to be paranoid you have
to anticipate other people's next moved
and moves and you can't ever you know
downplay the competition you know I was
telling I was at a business plan
competition this morning for at a
college and they were kind of being
dismissive of the competition and so you
can't ever do that you know they're out
there trying to take you down and
they're not just gonna sit still and if
you're good really really good you're
gonna inspire them to work even harder
faster better and so you have to be you
know very self aware of what you're good
at and what other people are good at and
you know a healthy dose of paranoia
makes a bit dear me it's very helpful so
that's interesting you say that so
sometimes you know you'll be a little
bit too paranoid you know you're being
too concerned about this too concern
about that the other question for you
would be mark you don't run one company
you run many companies you're doing
deals all the time and there is this
notion that you hear multitasking right
on the you can multitask you can do this
so your brain if I were to take a
hundred percent ok 10 percent here seven
percent your 6 percent here how do you
process all of it here in your mind with
the difference that has to be something
I'm really good at right you know I just
I process things very quickly
and that's always been my strength I can
I can identify what's going on typically
faster than anybody and and crying right
through it and plus you know I because I
force everybody to email or cyberdust
it's all coming from one flow right it's
all one funnel and so I'm not bouncing
from meeting to meeting thinking okay
what did we say in that meeting we're
having to take notes and then we're
having somebody take notes you know it's
like it's already in writing it's in an
email and if it's in cyberdust is like
having a face-to-face and when I see it
I respond to it immediately kind of
cyber has forced me to respond to it
immediately
um and so that that allows me to keep
things organized and stay on top of
things and you know so you know anything
that's unread that's my to-do list and
that's all I stay on top of it got it so
I've become a phonetic side of this
there's an every other hour I'm chicken
side when you told me you know go check
outside with us and then from there I we
got everybody on the company now
everyone out here the only way you gonna
get to see this first you got it and I
would like the link I will do what I
mentions to get everybody closer but I
love the product and we'll get to that
because I want to explain how I see side
with us you're not as a CEO as a
customer because I want people to see
how I see it as a customer let's talk
about speed when people ask me and say
hey you know how do I get speed going I
want to see your perspective on this
because cyber does has a tipping point
you know you got Twitter has a tipping
place but everything is about the
tipping point in your mind how does one
entrepreneur increase the speed in areas
that they can increase there's certain
things you can't be in one way speed of
growing your business all right
so how fast can I grow yeah I mean it
just depends you've got to know your own
skill set right and you've got to know
how that fits within your company's
lifecycle um you know some companies are
slow slow grind and you just have to
understand that and you've just got to
bide your time and still until it starts
to click and then grow with it quickly
you know if you're trying to release a
product that needs to be ubiquitous
you've got to go as fast as you can and
and then you know release a product yeah
no long yeah and and you know there's a
lot of people will say you know
perfection is the enemy of profitability
right and that doesn't mean you have to
to us a perfect product you know
cyberdust is perfect and we still
haven't it's been almost two years we
still haven't advertised it yet because
we know it's not ready yet you know and
so it's been a slow growth grind because
that's we wanted we want feedback you
know we want to keep on learning we're
evolving but it really just depends on
what the product is that you know a
barber shop right isn't an app is it a
service is it a product but you know the
the key is looking for the low-hanging
fruit what are the app what are what
customers are willing to write you a
check or commit to it you know so that
they're willing to integrate it into
their daily lives or integrated into
their daily business and so getting a
commitment either through time or
revenue is typically what I look for and
so if I can get a commitment then I'm
gonna be able to learn I'm gonna see how
they use it to they sustained usage and
then once I get the next one you know
hopefully it came a little bit faster
than the first one then I can ask for
referrals and then the next one then the
next one and I just tried to ramp it up
you know when I bought the Mavs we had
no season ticket-holder base and so
literally it was a matter of just
putting a list of former season ticket
holders and a white pages back then you
know on my desk next to my phone and
making phone calls you yeah me yeah
because if I'm not gonna do it I'll find
someone else to do it right so just get
on the phone hey this mark you know I'm
the new owner of the Dallas Mavericks
we've you know I'd like to invite you
back where again it's not though this is
my business you we can't get regular
sales gets or something make those calls
wants to get to a corner you're a guy
that's a billion you're making them but
that's all you know and that's fine and
good right because everybody's got their
own goals right and but still I don't
want anybody at the Mavs to be able to
said well he's not willing to do the
work right there's you know if I walk
around I'm picking up all the papers I'm
not saying go get that picked up I'm
like okay that's trash I'm picking it up
so but in terms of speed of growth it's
really you got to get that first
customer first and then when you get
that first what did you learn reiterate
get that next customer and then
hopefully as you learn more and more
through the process than the next one
the next one the next one becomes coming
by and faster you know it's interesting
when we walked in here and I appreciate
that on two speeds
we walked in here typically when I want
to know how does to work for somebody
you got to ask people around them or you
can ask the processor to work for you
right we get the right answer so that's
the security guy had this guy said oh
you know mark country's gonna say hi to
everybody he's gonna do this he's gonna
do that and they were all like fans they
love work yes cuz we have cameras and
microphones that's classic
that's classic okay let's transition to
a different subject let me see what time
okay let's transition to a different
subject with college you went to IU
yep right now you got a lot of people
that say forget about school you know
you're out of school they're idiots oh
you think they're idiots
tell me what if you're gonna have and
run a business if you don't understand
accounting you're already behind the
eight ball can't you hire a guy that's
good no second day they still have to
communicate to you right I mean there's
people that don't understand the concept
of you know the difference between
profits and cash you know oh your
accountant might tell you you're
profitable but your cash is going down
you know not understanding that
breakdown and and when you don't you
thing you need college to learn that
yeah I think you do right because it may
not for some people look if you're so
self-motivated that you can take an
online course in accounting and teach
yourself everything you're way ahead of
the game anyways but most people aren't
and I'm not saying you have to go to
Indiana
I'm not saying going an expensive school
I don't care if you go to a community
college and take accounting and spend 99
bucks for the class just you know
spending the money forces you to be more
obligated to do it but accounting
finance lesser extent marketing sales of
the school offers that these are
although that's the language of business
and so while it's possible to teach
yourself these things and while it's
possible to hire them when you're
starting your own company
you don't want to have to spend money
hiring an accountant right you're
already probably gonna have to hire a
lawyer to set up your your well let me
take that if you've gone through all
these classes if I don't have to hire a
lawyer to incorporate right you'll
probably figure out yourself and so your
cost of opening up a business drops but
even more important and all that that's
that's the block unit tackling that's
the language of business you know the
thing I learned at Indiana that was more
important than anything else I learned
how to learn
and learning became far more important
to me because the one certainty in
business is that it's always going to be
changing the if you're not always
learning to this minute if I'm not
continuously learning if I'm not just
absorbing as much as I can absorb
someone else is going to kick my ass
right so you talked about paranoia the
the greatest source of your paranoia
should be knowledge if someone else
knows more than you do and if you're not
learning if you don't know the Lord if
you don't know how to learn if you don't
have a thirst for learning and acquiring
information you're you're Sol do I need
to go to school to have that though so
make it maybe let me restate the
question would be the question the
question will be do I need to get a
bachelor's degree so what's you just
obviously necessary you have to have the
degree okay write something Branca you
have to have the knowledge holy I
totally agree with that fair enough okay
let's so let's skip that part and go
into a little bit of politics and you
know our conversations start I said mark
you know I said man you gotta get up
there because you got such a big fan
base people want to hear your opinions
about politics you may want to run for
president one day and we were going back
with the thing and I said mint
people got to know who is what is Mark
thinking about cuz a lot of times CEOs
don't want to touch polyps right they
don't want to touch it at all for
whatever reason if you were the
president today Mark Cuban is the
president
February 1st 2016 what are three things
you're attacking income inequality right
improving the ability for companies to
raise capital through IPOs I think
that'll have a big impact on the market
you've touched that on Inc you said that
on the incas well so let's talk about
income inequality rl1 so how do you do
that so right now let's just say you're
making thirty five thousand dollars a
year and you're clearing fifteen hundred
bucks a month after tax okay and you
live like a student I don't care if you
have thirty forty fifty what sure you're
living like a student and you're able to
save five hundred bucks a month okay
where you sleep are you staying at home
you're living at home right with your
hey two-year-old parents you're 50 years
old um there's a lot of that right now
yeah unfortunately and so you're saving
six grand a month right well right now
with interest rates near zero
surrounding you
or six grand a year um so you're saving
six grand a year five hundred bucks a
month which is amazing that's what every
Republican wants you to do that's what
every Democrat wants you to do try to
control your own destiny now you put it
in the bank or do you put it in stocks
no one trusts the stock market no one
really knows what they're doing right no
you put it in to a fund but the problem
is if you put into a fund because you're
not making a lot of money if the
dishwasher breaks right you get
penalized for taking and show that money
out so we're in a situation right now
where it's if you put that money into
the bank which is really only the safe
way you know six thousand a year and a
year you'll have six thousand and sixty
dollars okay sure you're just not ever
going to be as bad if that right and the
point being is you're never going to
improve your place in life right where
the 1% really the reason income has
become so unequal is I can hire anybody
I want to help me pick the best
investments and I do most of it myself
but I'm decent at it right so I can put
my money in stocks I could put my and
hedge against the risk I can put my
money in whatever but I'm liquid so I
don't have to worry about the dishwasher
break-in guy if you would have six
thousand dollars how are you going to
keep up right how are you going to
improve your position in life even if
you spent twenty years saving six
thousand dollars a year that's $120,000
but you've earned $1,500 in interest
that whole time right and while 120
thousand is good you're not gonna be
able to live off of that when you hit
sixty five or seventy years old right
not at all so part of the challenge is
how do you allow people to accumulate
capital okay without the risk of waking
up one day and not being able to get the
money out for their dishwasher or their
car or paying for their kids school
right we're not um we're finding that
the stock market is way down and they're
basically wiped out and so to me that's
the first thing to address and so I
think you know one ways the Federal
Reserve I don't think you mess with the
Federal Reserve but I think you come up
with savings certificates savings bonds
that literally pay a little bit more
that allow people to save for their
future because I think that helps people
protect their future that allows people
to build more of an asset base and that
takes them you know gives them a comfort
level that they're gonna be able to
survive is
as they age and take care of their
expenses and maybe then maybe they can
buy a house you save up enough money
earn enough and an interest or whatever
it may be to buy a house but you just
you know it's not so much pulling the
top down as in bringing the bottom up
and then I would also increase the
minimum wage and the way I would there's
a couple different ways to look at it
but in my mind like this past December
we gave everybody here a raise to a
minimum of $10 an hour and the reason I
did it is I found out there were people
that work for me that were on government
assistance in one way or another you
know might be a program but I hate the
idea that I'm subsidizing somebody you
know the fact that I'm not paying enough
everybody's taxes is subsidizing this
person's life you know you think about
that and so you get a lot of business
owners saying oh you can't raise the
minimum wage well all of us pay for the
fact that you're not paying that person
enough and will it change the
competitive balance well if everybody's
having to pay more then the competitive
balance still say it's somewhat
competitive will the markets change some
but it's not so much that I think
raising the minimum wage is a great idea
but what I don't like is the fact that
we are subsidizing low wages for certain
for businesses and so I think you know
maybe there's a better way the minimum
wage so I'm just talking off the top
show that sure of course but the bottom
line is that people who work for me
shouldn't have to use government
services funded by everybody and until
we get people off of that incoming
inequality interesting it's just gonna
be kind of convoluted your approach will
be the government doing something about
it well it's not so much the government
doing something about I wanted to get
people off the government assistance got
it right so how about this part you know
there used to be time when the whole
Ford Motor Company came out with you
know working 9:00 to 5:00 and when they
came out with this after the Great
Depression you know what that's why at
night 9:00 to 5:00 is only a 90 year old
system right so when they came out with
that you and I said okay I'll give you
30 years of my life and I'm for it you
know we said hey but what are you gonna
give me if I give you 30 years of my
life so they said we'll give you a
pension right in 1984 we have 130
something something pension plans
thousand one hundred thirty seven
thousand pension today we have 24 right
I think we've gone away from that
because
it sounds like from what your concern is
on income inequality is the first point
you made is $500 a month times 12 months
$6,000 so long term 20 or 7 or $20,000
which means they may not have long term
money for retirement but if we go away
from the pension plan
so do they probably go right away to the
pound and advise companies well the
problem with pensions is the uncertainty
of business right so what's happening
with pensions now Serna they've got to
grow them just because to support the
amount of money required for the
employees they can't they can't find
that return right so if if I either got
a if everybody's Arne only earning 1%
and your pension matches your salary I
mean okay just for the and you're making
$36,000 a year I've got to find a way as
a business owner to fund thirty six
thousand dollars per year for the you
know so that you're making twenty or
seventy right right a math for that's 65
to 85 yeah but but if you're only
earning 1% the rule of 72 says it takes
three years right so I've got a you know
you don't get 72 years so I've got a fun
three-quarters of it or whatever so what
would it be with the solution will be
you know we can move away from this
topic would it be given an incentive for
companies who do give pension plans up
to this I just don't I don't think
companies it's mathematically yeah I did
yeah I don't think it works simply
because there's too much uncertainty on
the are not big thing of it the key of
it is what what elements of certainty do
you put on businesses right a pension is
a certain amount that you have to pay
but you're it's uncertain how much
you're going to earn you know if whether
it's minimum wage or some other way of
doing it or you know working so that
whatever it is right so that you don't
need government assistance then that's
just part of your current business you
know and so it's really I guess it's
more about coming to you or I as a
business owner and said okay if you're
making a million dollars a year would
you be okay with making seven hundred
fifty thousand dollars a year and your
attack on another 250 on it know
whatever there's no tax no tax no no tax
a way they say to you why don't you pay
your guys more that's what you're a
guilt type thing right you know and so
you know I've said I would react of
Ehrman government of dollars I know you
like a cross a type of yeah let's go out
there and do this like what did you do
my drive yeah how much more money
look I've literally received that
happening yeah I've literally written
checks to the Dallas City Treasury you
know when the Mavs won a championship I
paid for the pray that when we needed
extra police overtime I wrote the check
for it because it's not fair to ask all
the citizens of Dallas to pay the taxes
for something that benefits me like that
would you consider yourself a capitalist
you're full on capital oh yeah but see
what's changed with capitalism it I mean
I'm a hardcore we're not a full on
capitalism you know that we know we're
not that what we've evolved right and so
you know 90 years ago the Henry Ford
days sure if you didn't have a job and
you couldn't afford it you found
somebody's floor to sleep on and you
went with your family or whatever you
know and if it was 12 to a room that's
the way it was and then over time we
started having you know you know with
with FDR we started having you know
basic services that we would provide for
you and then over time with LBJ there
was more services right and and welfare
services and now you know we're not
gonna let you drop dead in the streets
we want you know you anybody can walk
into a hospital or or now we want you to
have these about them I think it's right
I think it's you think it is right look
I'm so what would call you a Democrat
and no no hell no no no look there's
there's different things for different
reasons right if we as a society decide
that we don't want people dropping dead
in the streets or you know just dying at
home then there's a cost to that and we
can't expect insurance companies and
hospitals just to pick up that cost for
decisions we make as a society just like
we want TSA at the airport just like we
want you know Homeland Security you know
should we say look don't pay for it
we'll just all get blown up right
there's certain minimum services that
we've all defined that's evolved
capitalism and we all have to pay for
that but at the same time that doesn't
destroy the root of capitalism and who
we are and and the incentives right it
just means that we're gonna take a chunk
off the top now on the flip side of that
how we do that how you pay for it that's
a different beast is the government too
big yes
is the government inefficient yes if for
every you know I'd rather the government
have one half the employees and just
write checks to people you know the old
helicopter dropped of cash
you know just drop cash on the people
because they're just gonna spend it
these are people who can't afford to say
economy yeah and so I'd rather you know
you talk about what would you do as the
president probably the third thing I
would take all these services we have
and cut I would say to everybody okay
here's two years three years severance
and then I'm gonna take 75% of what's
left and just consolidate it all
together and write everybody who
qualifies the cheque right and then you
know to go to you know you know yeah but
you use that money or but I get crushed
by all the union's right because there's
like yeah this would be anti control
votes now yeah exactly so it's very
anti-union we you know in somewhat
somewhat socialist and you can argue
about creating distance and you'd have
to work those things but the one
certainty is governments to big
government is inefficient and there's
way to cut ways to cut back on the
amount of money you spend so what does
it take to pay for all the services we
as a country feel are legit for our
citizens whether it's health care
security whatever it may be and what's
the best way to do that and I literally
rather than saying here's 30 programs
you have to sign up for and here's all
the overhead associated with managing
those services and monitoring and
checking for fraud here's a check here's
your $800 a month you know in addition
to Social Security no accountability no
account of no accountable right because
now because you can't get it anywhere
else right now
you this has got to take care of your
life if you don't do it they're sorry
right we've eliminated the excuse there
is a limit to where listen if you do
nothing with this there's nothing else
we can do right at that point is they
sense yeah at that point you know your
family's also getting paid right you're
on your own right but trying to say okay
you've got to do this program this
program this program this program is
just so saturated with overhead it
doesn't work that is such an interesting
topic that's off the table so would you
be comfortable with a capitalist like
Donald Trump being our president um the
capitalist side yeah I don't have a
problem with in I like Donald and he's
smart
I just what's concerning is the way all
the candidates Republican or Democrat
are trolling for votes I mean they're
just pandering you what do you need what
do you want me to say I'll say it in
order to get you vote he's sane would
hell yeah
you think he's saying whatever people
want him to say pretty much yeah now Wow
within the realm of what gets votes
right so within the realm of what gets
most right so yeah it's not just when
you want me to say right so I need I
need to appeal to ultra-conservatives in
order to get elected in the primary and
so if I'm appealing to
ultra-conservatives what to all Cultra
conservatives want you know we started
with immigration that fit now you know
everything he says and does it's okay
what's the playbook for getting voters
for the primary now do I think once he's
elected president he'll follow through
for all those with all those things no
because most of them won't work and he's
and do I think he's smart enough to
figure that out and then just do the
right thing after he's elected yes so
you know with like a lot of candidates
and politicians you vote for not what
they say but knowing that 99% of they
say won't come true what they'll do the
rest one who's gonna follow through with
a lot because they know that what you
already know he's not gonna get a wall
built right he's not gonna get all these
things done it's just not gonna happen
and there's no money to do it so slice
those off and what will happen when you
just put the guy in the office so what
do you think that the American people
should ask about Trump as a president if
there's one question what would it be
is it the same thing you're saying that
do you really think he's gonna deliver
on all this now because he knows I mean
look when when he him and all I'm not
this isn't just Donald right this is
everyone at every single Hillary right
because when they put the other tax pay
all we're cutting the tax to all this we
used a number from this tax group right
it doesn't add up right and they say oh
it's gonna cost you know 30 trillion
dollars over ten years
oh no the economy will increase so much
right right you know it's BS right do
you process the boat though you got to
pick somebody to vote for house what
comes out look we got 12 months right
show me nothing matters too late yeah
right and so we got lots of time and you
know things will start right now
they can play Alice in Wonderland and
just throw things up and it doesn't
matter right I mean because none of
their tax plans work and then Hillary or
Bernie saying okay tax the 1% and
that'll pay for everything doesn't work
right
won't work you know Hilary's um pay for
college her plan is ridiculous it'll
increase college costs not reduce you
know so they don't they don't think them
through they just say okay here's here's
my justification but over time don't
have to start thinking them through and
they'll have to start dealing and
addressing some facts and then at that
point in time you say okay knowing that
none of this is ever going to pass who's
still going to be the best president
when it's all said and done it's gonna
be very interesting it is very very
interesting on what's gonna happen so
let's do it let's do a couple things
here with fun and then we'll go into
cyber to wrap it up sports you know
Dallas and what happened with our you
know we can say runaway bride if you
want to call it oh yeah it's super got
it
runaway bride with what happened with
them if you were to ever call back this
season let's just say because my opinion
is this I think if the clips don't pull
it together this year I think
something's gonna break apart that's my
opinion I don't care if he called us he
wants to come and plead Alice would you
ever take a battle never so now he's
ever stating ever you never say never
right everybody deserves the second
chance
Chum you know dee will said no to us
initially and we brought it back
interesting right so you know I just
care about winning
and I'll put winning above ego anytime I
noticed with guys that get to your level
that there's got to be a level you have
a strong memory because you know enemies
everyone's got a target we got enemies
but there's also a level of forgiveness
when it comes down to it you're here to
win right oh so just make sense if the
opportunity arises yeah why not why not
right I I mean look it's basketball it's
not thermonuclear war right it's not
like you shot my cousin you know or you
know we're just you know cut off us
pinky right it's basketball oh my
goodness we think sometime we you know
when we drink some of these exciting
drinks you got back here sometime we get
a little bit more excited thinking it's
very very important exactly so you think
all them sick we go 73 or nine this year
yeah who knows right I hope not but
we'll see they're looking good yeah
they're really good looking very very
good some funk questions from your
favorite type of music what do you want
hip hop really even when you were
younger or was it kind
yeah yeah a classic funky hip-hop yeah
Tupac or biggie um probably biggie I
just like to beat more and it did you
know Tupac was more about you know the
message and Biggie was like let's just
party favorite decade of music
probably the 90s right now that we're
big isn't yeah okay you got a favorite
song you listen to during workout um
yeah I forget that a band that was
called I'm a beast whose mo beast you
know is I'm obese it's actually great
favorite movie of all time
oh gosh I don't have anyone I mean I'm
really into like into the world movies
so my wife always cracks up so any movie
that has like been yeah I like Sam yeah
Independence Day like San Andreas Fault
was a horrible movie but the whole place
was falling apart you know the day after
tomorrow I'll watch you know you name it
if the whole world is blowing up you
know and la is crumbling and there's
some big old thrust you know of water
you know wave of water coming through
New York I was like that's why I did
sharknado 3 right it's the end of the
world are you two cars are not redundant
it - I have a Lexus but I'm Bonnie - got
it
favorite room in the house I know you
living in a big cast you got like a real
cool place you vote for yourself like
some like no not like this because
actually my house was perfect when I had
no furniture I mean I my buddies came
over I could throw a football we played
wiffle ball I mean we had one bin size
inside yeah and what we would do you
know like imagine you know you drive
over the sofas you can catch a pass and
you roll off the sofa like you just got
tackled it was perfect then I got
married things changed when that happens
real quick so um iPhone or droid both I
carry one of each two different networks
so if my network is bad on one I have
the other and I get the test and play
with all actually you prefer more it
just depends on the app really so you're
both yeah what I like let me be
independent is what I like what I like
about Android is that with Samsung has
replacement batteries so I just carry an
extra battery on
but on the flip side iOS batteries seem
to last longer so there's pluses and
minuses to both so yeah I don't know if
you heard him say this iOS batteries
tend to last longer to all my droid
friends out there yeah okay
so let's talk about cyber yes uh-huh
this has become the app that I check
probably the most on a daily base
outside of YouTube good and YouTube I
checked because of what we got going on
but this is a very very exciting app
tell me the story behind why cyberdust
sure um back in 2013 I had a trial
against the SEC the SEC accused me of
insider trading and in the trial as part
of their discovery they took all my
emails and some of the most innocuous
emails you know when I wrote them
thought okay this is really you know
this means absolutely nothing they would
take and they turned him into like oh
this is proof you did X Y & Z like I
said I had one of my buddies Lee that is
the world's worst stock trader and I
said that in the email you know cuz he
asked me about the stock that I was
accused of insider trading mama calm and
I said you know no stay away from it
because I knew he would just lose money
figure out a way to lose money and I
said and you know when when the SEC
asked me about it I said no he's the
world's worst or threatened said no you
knew this stock was going down and you
just said that to protect him I'm like
that's ridiculous right so if someone
was that as simple as that just when
you're in an adversarial position
whether it's the SEC or any lost
interest right if you've ever done a
deposition right whatever you say the
other sized attorney is going to try to
turn it into something to their benefit
sure and and with emails with text it
loses context and when you really think
about it the minute you hit Send on an
email a text message a Facebook message
whatever it may be the minute you who
it's in you lose ownership of it but you
don't lose responsibility for it and
we're not talking about judging your
ownership but not responsibility very
interest right because if I send you an
email you own it now that's right right
if you want to say you know when I if I
said the sky is blue what an amazing day
you know and then
you know something comes out and you say
see he sent me this email he doesn't
really believe this guy is green you
know he may have said this guy's free
he's a liar right see Cubans a liar you
know and so you can take anything I said
you know if if my daughter has a friend
who you know finds her lost iPad which
would be a calamity and she says I love
you for this thank you so much you're
the best thing that ever happened to me
and some little schmucky little kid says
Oh from Alexis I have this email and she
says she loves me see right that
responsibility that context can change
forever that's why I started cyberdust
so from a business perspective I do
didn't like the fact that I lost control
of all my emails no matter where they
were
since particularly since I do everything
via email at the time I didn't like the
fact that anybody could keep it whether
or not I liked it or not right
from and so and I also like the fact
that because it disappeared it was like
a face-to-face conversation so when you
and I talked via cyberdust it's like
talking here now sure except now it's
being recorded but you know - the camp -
the camp it's right if you take the
picture name doesn't say Dave doesn't so
nominal but even yeah but even if you
take a screenshot right not only does it
not say who it came from but it sends me
an alert and you know you talk if
someone were to have a whole group of
screenshots trying to reassemble a
conversation you're gonna know something
was wrong in the first place right
because you're not gonna if you want
them to save it you're not gonna have
that conversation inside with us if I'm
sending you something I want you to save
I'm gonna say I'm what's your email
right cuz you don't you you use email
less right but you know you still can
use email here's a contract here's you
know let's discuss the terms we need to
memorialize that's great but for having
what would otherwise be in a
face-to-face conversation for anything
that is just a business conversation I'm
gonna use cyber dust every time and so
that's why I created it and when we
created it you know like anything else
like any other business I thought this
would be big for kids right sorry it's
like kids it's the post snapchat
generation that really is into it people
who think in terms of words people who
communicate ideas you know as opposed to
here's a picture of my lunch
you fell it commented on
snap check if they has made a very big
mistake they I need a very big miss yeah
they said every say yeah and that
benefits cyber does I mean positioning
wise that was not a good move on there
right now and that's okay I mean they're
fine not worried about anything
but at the same time you know we're kind
of like if you will snapchat for
grown-ups
you know when once you get past here's
pictures of my lunch at for grown-ups
yeah you know if four people wonder so
if you've only used snapchat you're
trying to figure out what it is right
because snapchats all about pictures
it's not about communications cyber to
us is about communicating ideas it's a
you know you can send links you can send
it from one to one person and then send
it to a hundred or a thousand or a
million people that follow you cyber
dust is about being able to have a
private conversation
privacy creates honesty if we're having
a conversation and you and I could talk
about politics and I can beat like we
did and I could be brutally on and you
were and I was right because it's not
going everywhere and the minute if you
took a snapchat a snapshot I'm not
talking about anymore right right and
and then I can it's not for me right
because it doesn't have my hair so that
privacy really makes people a lot more
candid and if you and if you're in a big
business as an example your lawyers will
always tell you you know write an email
knowing that someone else is going to be
reading it and it could be a lawyer from
an opposing counsel right you don't have
to do that with cyberdust you can just
be honest and to me that moves forward
the conversation and makes businesses
more effective do you think politicians
people who are of influence that
everything is held against them do you
think people would you know public
figures they need to start transitioning
away from Twitter to cyber that's what
you're saying oh yeah and there's a lot
to do and they just do it on a private
basis you'd be shocked at the be a level
names and the people that use cyber dust
and then if told me and the politicians
and you know because I can see that I'm
oh yeah this morning you know 90% of our
usage is 9:00 to 5:00 you know and so
you know it's putting doing it on
Twitter whatever your whole whether
you're 16 26 66 right everything you do
in social media creates a footprint that
says who you are anybody I hire right
that's going to direct for me I'm
looking at Twitter I'm looking at
Facebook I'm looking at their Instagram
I'm following them on snapchat because
it all creates a profile who they are
and now there's machine learning that's
going through and analyzing these things
and saying okay Patrick is this and I
know that because here's all his social
media posts and it's going to be a whole
lot worse if you're 16 17 18 and you've
got this whole long history or some of
this it's not an issue obviously and
they're coming out with websites are
coming I would wait to try to audit you
to be able to figure out what you think
you're yes of course there are
everything you know everything well I'll
tell you my opinion outside with us so
some of the people that are watching is
I love cyber that's when I first
switched to cyber does and I started
messing with it the first couple things
was well you know what how do I know who
the message comes from all group and all
you got to do is hold a picture comes up
which was all right yeah all these
different colors how to know who is this
so I had to do that then you know the
screenshot you have to learn the
screenshot that if you have to get
something that you want to save hey get
this email screenshot I can save that
okay great that helped me out but I put
it in three different categories so I
use dust as a text right that's how I
look at dust right I use blast as they
tweet how I look at it right as you can
send it but the good thing is I have
groups right on who I can tweet to right
just great really right yeah then I like
the group dust right and on the group
dust I can look at that as group me
that's group text it's just privacy it's
private it's an oh group me is becoming
very slow so fun whether I'm running an
organization sales organization a
company it doesn't matter I can
categorize those three and it's working
amazingly well for me right now so I'm
I'm a big fan of okay yeah cyber dust in
a major major way so it's like I get
like I follow you on cyber too so I get
your motivation he's enough and I'll be
blasted a lot right you get the stuff
that I put out there on whether it's on
business or motivation or stuff like
that so and the cool part about it when
you tweet something like on your Twitter
on your Instagram on YouTube right no
matter what you tweet or put out there
someone's gonna bust on you for it right
there's always going to be a troll that
trolls you from one way and in the back
your mind you're always thinking okay
how somebody going to nail me on this
you never have to do that on cyber is
because if I say something you don't
agree with and you come back
math suck well 30 seconds later it's
gone right and I can block you and you
don't know it and and but the better
part is no one else sees it on Twitter
if they say well you know what
you suck right your company sucks
everybody sees that's right right and
you don't want to deal with that knowing
that everybody's gonna see there is one
very very good point you just made I
didn't even think about that so you're
not talking about me saying you suck I'm
held to it
right you're saying it's a brand another
person says you suck right so when I go
sir yeah when I go search for your
company very good point so when you
search for Mark Cuban or M cube in my
Twitter handle you see all the people
say oh you're an idiot cube and you suck
why did you do this why did you do that
right I don't put anything of
consequence on Twitter anymore
Twitter's like a PR News we're a lot
less on Twitter than you were taller
years ago not even a question on it's
night and day not notice about anything
a consequence I put on cyberdust and
blasted up right and so a patrick says
oh that was an interesting concept we
can have a conversation and it's private
right on Twitter if you say something
that I'm interested one I'm living it to
140 characters - we could go to direct
message and do it that way but you could
still keep it all right three everybody
else is going to see the conversation
and it's going to jump in and add their
own two cents and so it becomes such a
public medium that you can't it's no
longer social whereas was cyberdust
if 30 people respond respond to
something I blast out there I can deal
with them one to one and if I like
something I can say hey would you mind
if I read last this or you know
screenshot it and send it to everybody
and if I want to I can and so you get
the best of all worlds yeah I'm a big
big fan of it you know we use it in so
many we have everybody in the field
getting it use it and then the
interesting thing is the speed is very
it's getting faster faster and faster it
was a little bit but like this within a
month could change every month you're
seeing something worried that's not
gonna better and better I love it I'm
looking forward to using it a lot more
as well
so III have a feeling you know I was in
front of a group of guys and I see guys
go get cyber does a challenge sometimes
is you know Gary Vaynerchuk he got big
on YouTube early with my library you had
some some of these Twitter guys with
himself he's got 1.1 million followers
but on Twitter he got involved right off
the bat right so yeah I've got 4 million
right
and it helped that I was there like I
said my suggestion to everybody is if
you're not on if you if you don't have a
big presence on Twitter if Africa it's a
lot easier go get a big before cyberdust
got 5 million users I'd rather have a
little we get the right sir but yeah so
if you add yourself so if you want to
get followers and you're looking to
build a following on Twitter it's really
hard right and you know if you built
enough build up a thousand followers on
Twitter it's probably taking you
multiple years and half of them are
dormant or BOTS right on cyberdust there
are no BOTS first of all and if you add
yourself to chatters then you're going
to be able to get followers and we have
a follow Friday like Twitter does right
and we'll put out there people to follow
but also we're going to be improving our
discovery mechanism significantly here
over the next two months and so because
to your point we want regular everyday
people to be able to get a thousand two
thousand five thousand followers we're
on Twitter they might have 150 followers
and most of those are just follow backs
or bots and so it they're not really a
consequence so no doubt about it
Twitter they did a number saying Twitter
their biggest criticism is only 24% of
users are real oh really
everyone else that's great not real
because they sell thousands fake
followers because you know now that I
can write fake file right right and then
you know so that's yeah none of the
world bots don't work you can't bought
ours
you can bot cyberdust that's great
that's great well you know again mark
thank you for your time I want to give
you this book and I want you to open the
front of everybody I just want to show
you if you actually have it or not they
do have it you can give it away to
somebody and I use I these incredible
specials Wow nobody's no life I don't
have five of these but I have at least
four now is it a first print for studio
without a person further this is the
first French first edition 1957 I found
it oh um Beverly Hills it's not a third
edition it's first first of all set
original what that's amazing Wow
yeah and I got it for you because when
we were in Nashville I got up and asked
you a question I said hey book that
impact you to most you said and ran
after shrug that's it
I can now really get better to get it
for you so there was another three weeks
that we really fell like the tenth time
thank you that's research it's a great
gift thank you so much and folks
everybody out there watching this you
obviously know everybody loves this man
for his honest direct
whether you like it or not he's gonna
give you the direct opinion on anything
with business one share this video with
other people to go get cyber dust app
download it and tell your friends to
also get on cyberdust and start using it
and you know many times you'll be
surprised you sent him a message you'll
be surprised with him responding back
trying to respond them all and I
guarantee you I'm gonna try to motivate
you like like Patrick I try to do as
many motivational great love you so much
yeah what's your user at cyber dusted a
conviction also is just plug my or an
hour yeah blog member blog maverick once
again thank you I don't appreciate about
that